firebase is Google's mobile and web app
development platform and it offers many
useful cloud services so you might
wonder what is the relationship between
firebase and Google cloud platform stick
around and I'll help you understand you
may know a firebase for all the features
it offers to enhance your client app
such as authentication analytics crash
reporting a be testing or in-app
messaging but firebase also has several
options to manage data and business
logic in the cloud to help you build
better apps this includes NoSQL database
service functions on device and
server-side machine learning api's blob
storage and more firebase is a wonderful
way for Android and web developers to
leverage Google cloud services without
exposing them to all the knobs and dials
of GCB in fact when you create a
firebase project it is a GCP project in
every aspect resource grouping identity
management and billing are all the same
this gives you a great way to start
using some cloud services before you
graduate into using GCP only when you
need to this is also important to any
user interested in building and mobile
or web app on top of an existing GCP
infrastructure while the look and feel
of the firebase console and cloud
console are clearly different you can
open the same project with either one if
you'd like to open an existing GCP
project in the firebase console to add
firebase specific functionality simply
select add a project and click through
the few setup steps once done all the
firebase KPIs will be automatically
enabled in your project if you have an
existing firebase project simply head
over to cloud console and open it there
with its identifier you should see and
be able to manipulate all of the project
resources finally you want to be careful
about deleting projects as deleting a
firebase project deletes the Google
cloud projects as well and all its
contained resources so now that you know
that a firebase project is also GCP
project let's focus on the three main
products that firebase and GCB have in
common
cloud storage a massively scalable blob
storage system
cloth functions a service compute
infrastructure for event-driven
programming and cloud 5 store a
massively scalable no SQL database these
three GCP products can be used in
firebase with additional mobile SDKs as
well as from the firebase CLI or command
line interface we'll cover the first one
now and the other two in the next video
so make sure you subscribe to this
channel cloud storage is a powerful yet
simple to use blob storage system and if
you have not heard of it then you should
check out the short data and storage
overview video link below cloud console
exposes the full power of cloud storage
while the firebase console exposes those
features that are most likely to be
relevant to firebase developers a
typical use case for firebase developers
using cloud storage is when managing
user generated content this is where the
firebase android/ios web
unity and C++ SDKs make it easy and yet
secure to upload and download objects
such as images straight from the app
similarly to GCB projects using App
Engine any new firebase project comes
with a default cloud storage bucket in
most cases firebase developers also use
this default storage location and thus
do not need to reference it by name
because of all the GCP and firebase
commonalities discussed so far any data
stored in cloud storage using firebase
can be further access and processed in
GCB and vice-versa
imagine for instance a firebase powered
mobile applications uploading pictures
to cloud storage it would be quite easy
for a cloud scheduler initiate a task to
resize crop delete or otherwise
manipulate all pictures in this default
bucket you can also feed these files
into other GCP big data products such as
bigquery data flow or even into our
machine learning products one thing that
you will want to note is how bucket
access control is different and
orthogonal cloud iam is used to control
access to buckets and objects from GCP
services on the other hand firebase
security rules control access only from
mobile application
that use the firebase SDKs so they're
you now know how data stored in cloud
storage can be equally accessed via
firebase powered app as well as from
your GCP hosted applications in the next
episode we'll discuss the two remaining
products common to both platforms cloud
functions and cloud fire store same
project and billing infrastructure
common cloud storage the two platforms
have a lot in common
and we're conceived to nicely complement
one another it's time to get going with
firebase or GCP or both thanks for
watching this video please like
subscribe comment share and look forward
to more GCP essentials videos
[Music]